GOING TO CALL TO ORDER THE
ASSEMBLY UTILITY AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE HEARING FOR TUESDAY
JUNE NINTH- BEFORE WE BEGIN I'D
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CECILIA AGUILAR CURRY FOR
SITTING IN TODAY- FOR DOCTOR
QUIRK. THANK YOU FOR THAT- AS
WE ARE CONSTANTLY REMINDED
EVERYONE DUE TO THE CURRENT
SAID HOME ORDER WERE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS AND SO THERE IS A-
NEED TO- MAKE SURE THE NUMBERS
ARE SPREAD OUT- TODAY. IN THIS
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER WILL HAVE A
PHYSICALLY DISTANCE IN PERSON
HEARING IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY NO PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WE WILL
ALSO RECEIVE WITNESS TESTIMONY
FROM DIAL IN- WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATED. TELEPHONE
SERVICE THERE WHICH ANY WITNESS
CAN TESTIFY. ON THIS PRTICULAR
BILL TODAY. THE CALL IN NUMBER
FOR THIS HEARING IS AREA CODE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE.
TWO SIX. TWO FOUR TWO. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR VIEWING SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
IS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL IS
BEGINNING- HIS PRESENTATION.
THE OPERATOR HOLD THE LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THIS BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING
AND PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCASTING YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE SOUND DISTORTION.
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF
YOU ARE A MAIN WITNESS PROVIDED
TESTIMONY FOR AGAINST A BILL
YOU WILL REMAIN ONLINE. AND
WILL TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL
YOU'RE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. WE WILL HEAR ONE BILL
TODAY TESTIMONY FOR OUR PRIMARY
WITNESS AND PANELISTS ARE
LIMITED TO TWO MINUTES EACH.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES PLEASE
BRIEFLY STATE YOUR NAME
POSITION AN AFFILIATION IF ANY.
WELL NOW CALL THE ROLL FOUR
CORE. PRESIDENT HER. CARE AND.
OKAY MEETING. RARE YEAH. I'D
NOW LIKE TO A WELCOME SENATOR
HILL- TO THE PODIUM AND 2%
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY- CENTER
HILL- THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND
LET ME JUST SAY IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE WORKING WITH YOU TO
FIND. A CONSENSUS ON YOUR BILL
THE MESSAGE HERE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR THE
WELCOME- AS THE AYE THE END FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT- SB
THREE FIFTY TODAY AND IT HAS
BEEN A PLEASURE WORKING WITH
YOU. NOT JUST THIS YEAR BUT
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS- ON ENERGY
ISSUES- AND ESPECIALLY WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND A
AND YOU FOR THE HARD WORK
MISTER CHAIR ON THIS MEASURE-
AND- AND REALLY PLEASED AT THE
REFINEMENTS THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO COME TOGETHER ON TO A AND I
ACCEPT ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS AS
OPPOSED. TO BEING ON PAGE SEVEN
OF THE ANALYSIS LAST YEAR IN IN
YOUR BILL MISTER CHAIR A. B.
TEN FIFTY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
IMPOSED STRICT CONDITIONS ON P.
JEANNIE TO EXERT BANG THREE. AS
A TRANSFORM UTILITY SB THREE
FIFTY HOLDS P. JEANNIE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR MEETING THOSE
REQUIREMENTS AND PROVIDES OUR
STATE WITH FAIL SAFE IN NEW
PEACH IN A FALL SHORT OF
EXPECTATIONS. SB THREE FIFTY
AUTHORIZES THE CREATION OF A
NEW ENTITY GOLDEN STATE ENERGY
AND NON PROFIT PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATION WHICH WOULD STEP IN
AND TAKE OVER IF PGP FAILS TO
EMERGE FROM BANKRUPTCY OR- IF
P. JEANNIE FAILS TO TRANSFORM
AS REQUIRED BY AB. TEN FIFTY
FOUR. IT THREE FIFTY IS A BILL
I HOPE WE NEVER NEED. BECAUSE
IF FIFTY IS TRIGGER IT WOULD
MEAN P. JEANNIE HAS FAILED US
ONCE AGAIN. I WILL GO INTO A
LONG DISCUSSION OF P. GENIES
FAILINGS. WE HAVE ALL WITH THEM.
FAR TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS FOR
FAR TOO MANY TIMES HAVING THE-
CALIFORNIA DESERVES A REFORM TO
P. JEANNIE. I HOPE PGD NEVER
STARTS ANOTHER WILDFIRE BECAUSE
ANOTHER PIPELINE EXPLOSION. I
HOPE WE ALL HOPE. THE P.
JEANNIE IMPROVES ITS SAFETY
RECORD AND IT'S ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE ALL HOPE PGD FOR FILLS ITS
COMMITMENT TO TRANSFORM ITSELF
INTO A SAFE RELIABLE AFFORDABLE
IN RESILIENT UTILITY. BUT OUR
STATE CANNOT RELY ON HOPE A LOW.
SB THREE FIFTY IS OUR
CONTINGENCY PLAN. SHOULD THE
NEED ARISE SB THREE FIFTY
ENSURE THAT OUR STATE CAN TAKE
STRONG AND SWIFT ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS INCLUDING IF ULTIMATELY
NECESSARY THE CPUC REVOCATION
OF P. GENIES A LICENSE TO
OPERATE. SB THREE FIFTY AND I
CAN'T AND CANNOT EMPHASIZE THIS
ENOUGH IS ALSO CRITICAL FOR
WILD FIRE VICTIMS SHOULD P.
JEANNIE FAIL TO EXIT BANKRUPTCY
THE PATH LAID OUT IN SB THREE
FIFTY IS THE MOST EXPEDITIOUS
WAY TO RESOLVE THE VICTIMS
SETTLEMENTS AS THE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT IN THE ACCEPTED
ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS MAKE CLEAR.
HOW JESSE FIFTY ISN'T A BILL WE
WANT WHAT WE WANT IS FOR P.
GINNY TO BE A REFORMED UTILITY.
BUT IT IS A BILL WE NEED. TO
PROTECT P. GENIES RATE PAYERS.
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO
THE PROPER TIME I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR- WE WILL
HAVE ONE PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. AND WE WILL HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. OF THEIR
WILL TESTIFY FROM THE BACK OF
THE CHAMBER FLOOR. AND THERE
WILL BE THREE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES THAT WILL WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE THEIR CONCERNS. OF THE
THREE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL
BE TESTIFYING BY PHONE. OF
PHONE MODERATOR- WE WILL CALL
ON ADAM ON TO SANTOS WITH THE
OFFICE OF GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM. YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN WORK ON A LOT
OF HUNTERS HERE I JUST WANTED
TO- THANK- THE AUTHOR OF THANK
YOU THANK YOU COMMITTEE STAFF
AND THINK THE- THE MEMBERS OF
THE ROUNDTABLE THAT WORK WITH
OFTEN PARTNERSHIP- FOR SO MANY
MONTHS ON- RESOLUTION OF THE
BANKRUPTCY IN A MANNER THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
FOR. SAFETY WITH A SAFE
RELIABLE- CLEAN POWER VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THE
PARTNERSHIP AND APPRECIATE ALL
THE WAYS IN WHICH WORKING
TOGETHER. FOR A BETTER OUTCOME
FOR CALIFORNIA HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AND- ALL I GOT.
THANK ANOTHER CALL ON A GOT
WHICH WITH THE I. B. LOCAL
TWELVE FORTY FIVE. YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN THE MEMBER SCOTT WHICH
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES
AND IBEW LOCAL TWELVE FORTY
FIVE REPRESENTING THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES OF THE
PACIFIC GAS ELECTRIC COMPANY.
AS YOU KNOW MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WE HAVE STEADFASTLY
OPPOSED ANY BREAK UP HE
PROPOSED BREAK UP OF- PGD. WHAT
IS CHANGED TODAY IS THAT. IN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
GOVERNOR STAFF AND WITH THE
AUTHOR. IN A VERY THOUGHTFUL
PROCESS. THEY DEVELOPED A-
SMACK IN ISM IF WARRANTED TO
CREATE AN ENTITY THAT IS THE
ONLY IT'S A T. THE ONLY
PROPOSED INTO T. SUCCESSOR
ENTITY TO PGD. THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY PROTECT THE PENSION
AND COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
RIGHTS OF THOSE TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND WORKERS THAT I
REPRESENT. NEITHER THE SCOTT
SENATOR WIENER PROPOSAL. NEAT
NOR THE MAYOR OF SAN JOSE'S
PROPOSAL. CAN ACCOMPLISH THOSE
TWO THINGS FOR A MANY. ISSUES
RELATED TO FEDERAL LABOR LAW AS
WELL AS MANY ISSUES OF JUST
PRACTICALITY SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE SUPPORT THE BILL AND
URGENT I'VE A THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL NOW TURN TO THE THREE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE THEIR CONCERNS OF
PHONE MODERATOR- WILL CALL ON
SAN JOSE MAYOR SAM LICCARDO YOU
MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
AT THE CHAIRPERSON HOLDEN THAT
BREAKING MEMBER PATTERSON THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDER MY THOUGHTS. EVERY
LEADERSHIP IN THIS DIFFICULT
MOMENT- I HAVE MADE YOU KNOW
LARGER WE ASSEMBLED A COALITION
OF MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
ELECTED LOCAL OFFICIALS
REPRESENT MORE THAN NINE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. ARE
URGING TRANSFORMATION P.
JEANNIE BECOME A MORE RESPONSE
RESPONSIBLE. CONSTRUCT MORE ON
UTILITY WE APPLAUD SENATOR HILL
OF THE SPONSORS OF SB THREE
FIFTY FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS. TO
EMBRACE THE NONPROFIT CORPORATE
FORM FOR WHICH A COALITION AS
LONG ADVOCATED. TO ALTER THE
COMPANY'S OWNERSHIP STRUCTURE
TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC INTEREST
PREVAILS OVER SHAREHOLDER
INTEREST. OUR COALITION HAS
CONSISTENTLY EMPHASIZED THE
SECOND GOAL HOWEVER COULD
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE COST OF
CAPITAL FOR THIS UTILITY EVERY
DOLLAR INTEREST TOLD. PAY THE
HEDGE FOR THE HIGH YIELD DEBT
WITH THE PRIVATE OF RESOURCE
NEEDS TO INVEST. KATIE
RELIABILITY IMPROVEMENTS WILL
POST HIGHER RATED ON CUSTOMERS
WELL WE CAN YOU TELL THE
FINANCIAL VIABILITY. AT CENTER
THE UTILITY WILL REQUIRE
ANOTHER FORTY BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE NEXT HALF DECADE FOR
OVER TWO SAFETY RELIABILITY
IMPROVEMENTS. A FEW DOZEN BASIS
POINTS OF INTEREST WILL COST
REPAIRS AND RESIDENTS HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY
AND BILLIONS KIMBERLY. ALL THE
MANY CONVERSATIONS OF FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS AND EXPERT THE
FINANCIAL MARKETS REINFORCE THE
BASIC CONCLUSION THAT THE
FINANCIAL MARKETS WILL PUNISH
GOLDEN STATE IN THE POLL FORM
OF HIGHER FINANCING COSTS. TO
WHATEVER EXTENT APPEARS TO BE
VULNERABLE TO POLITICAL OR
REGULATORY RISK FINANCIAL
MARKETS RESPOND TO REST BY
RAISING PRICES THAT IS THE COST
OF CAPITAL. I THE SITE
PRINCIPAL FOR TWO REASONS IN MY
CONCLUSION FIRST A MANAGED
OPPOSE THE SB THREE FIFTY TO
ADD PERMANENT BOARD MEMBERS
APPOINTED BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR WILL DIRECTLY
RESULT. IN HIGHER COSTS TO
RATEPAYERS WITHOUT COMMENSURATE
BENEFIT RELIABILITY SHAKE YOUR
SERVICE QUALITY. SECOND WE URGE
THE CREATION AN ENTITY WITH THE
WAY THAT TAUGHT IN THE X. RAY
THAT PARTY THE ABILITY THAT
ENTITY TO CONTROL ITS RATE.
CAPITAL STRUCTURE IS THE
HALLMARK OF MORE THAN EIGHT
HUNDRED CUSTOMERS UTILITY
QUALQUER THROUGHOUT THE NATION.
WE EMBRACE REGULATION ICPC. OUR
STATE AGENCIES OVER SUCH ISSUES
AT STAKE THE LABOR BY NOW
STANDARD CLEAN ENERGY GOALS.
BUT NOT. WE CERTAINLY HAVE LET.
DESIRE TO MAKE STATE CALIBER
PUBLIC WHICH BE ASSURED BY
TOPIC MARYLAND MUTUAL. CORP ARE
STRUCTURE THAT WE'VE LONG URGED
I THINK YOU GIVING USING USE OF
OUR- AND BY THE WAY WE HAVE.
MANY MONTHS AGO AND I PRINCIPLE.
THAT WE WOULD PUT THE TECH. OF
ALL THE AB MEMBER AND ALL THE
MEMBERS. WHO WOULD BE EMPLOYEES
A THE NEW. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OF MODERATOR MARI ROSE WITH
RECLAIM YOUR POWER UTILITY
JUSTICE CAMPAIGN YOU MAY
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
HAVE A MOTOR DOWNTURN THERE IN
A VERY REAL. THE SECOND. CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN WE JUST
RECEIVED A MOTION OF
RECOGNIZING THE BILL THAT'S IN
FRONT OF US- FOR APPROVAL- DO
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS AND IT'S
BEEN SECONDED SO YOU MAY
PROCEED. AFTERNOON AND MERRY
RESTAURANT WITH TE RECLAIM OUR
POWER CAMPAIGN OR THE LARGEST
COLLECTION OF TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES WILDFIRES SURVIVORS
LOCAL CLEAN ENERGY ENERGY
ADVOCATES AND USED. FOR
CAMPAIGNING FOR UTILITY JUSTICE
TO MOVE US AWAY FROM THE P.
JEANNIE PRIVATE CORPORATE
MODEL. OUR CAMPAIGN OPPOSES-
THE BAIL OUT OF P. JEANNIE WE
WANT TO DEMOCRATIZE THEIR
ENERGY SYSTEM AND WE WANT TO.
REBUILD THE UTILITY SYSTEM FOR
ENERGY IN THE HUMAN RIGHT WE
WROTE OUR LETTER ON SB THREE
FIFTY THAT WE SUPPORT THE
CONCEPT IT'S AMENDED WITH FIVE
POINT- WERE VERY CONCERNED THAT
THIS SB THREE FIFTY PROCESSES
THE BULLET TRAIN. READY TO
LEAVE BEHIND THE MOST IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES- BUT WE REMIND YOU
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS BUILT
IN WAYS TO INCLUDE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AND
DECISION MAKING AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF MAJOR CLIMATE
AND ENERGY POLICIES- EXAMPLES
LIKE IT'S EIGHTY THIRTY TWO
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. TO THE PREVIOUS WELL
KNOWN AS THE THREE FIFTY OFTEN
ARE 100% CLEAN ENERGY COLD THAT
AND- THAT. INVOLVED BENEFITING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. WE
WANT A BILLTHAT INCLUDES
ANYONE TO SEE THAT INCLUSION
BUILT INTO THE GOVERNMENT TO
THE OF THE GOLDEN STATE. ENERGY
SYSTEM AND THAT ADVISORY CABLE.
INCLUDE US TO LAY THE
GROUNDWORK FOR THE NEW SYSTEM.
RECLAIM OUR POWER CAMPAIGN HAS
BEEN ASSEMBLING RESEARCH TEAM
ON HOW WE CAN REBUILD A UTILITY
THAT NEEDS COMMUNITY. AND WE
DON'T SEE THAT GET AN SB
TREASON AND ASK YOU TO TAKE
THOSE PAYMENTS CHEQUE CRUDE FAT
LIKE UNITY WORKERS IN THE
PROCESS AND GOVERNMENT OF THIS.
SYSTEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT TO PRESENT FROM MODERN.
MAY A CENSURE WITH MANUFACTURED
A SO. YOU PURSUE WITH YOUR TO.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS
THIS IS MY CASE ACCESS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION I PREFER
TO THINK THAT ARE HELD A CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THE CELL. AND
WORKING WITH THE TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS WITH THE LATEST
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT ACCEPTED BY
THE SENATOR WE HAVE REMOVED A
PETITION OF CONCERN. THE
PERFECTLY WE WERE PLEASED TO
SEE AMENDMENTS THAT INSURED
MEANINGFUL PARTICIPATION FOR
THE PUBLIC AT THE ANNOUNCED
WITH NOTED GOLDEN THE ENERGY
WITH BEING NON PROFIT PUBLIC
BENEFIT CORPORATION. BECAUSE OF
THIS THAT THE NATION REPAIRS
ARE COMPLETELY LIABLE FOR THE
UTILITY AND THEREFORE WE
BELIEVE IT'S PROPER THAT THE
TOILET. IT HERE TO TRANSPARENCY
STANDARD. MOREOVER WE GET THE
CARE. ON THE MEETING OF SKILLED
MATRIX THE OVERSIGHT BY THE PC
ON GREAT COVENANT
QUANTIFICATION. AND LASTLY THE
ABILITY FOR REPAIRS TO APPEAL
TO THE APPELLATE COURT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. WELL
NUMBER TO PUBLIC COMMENT- WE
ARE GOING TO FIRST LOOK TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
CHAMBERS WHICH I SEE NO ONE
ELSE HERE TO TESTIFY EITHER IN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OR AS A
TWEENER. PHONE MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YES THANK YOU AS A REMINDER IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FIFTY AND WOULD LIKE TO QUEUE
UP PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE WILL BEGIN WITH LINE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN HIGH
OUR LOOK AT INJURE I'M WITH
SUNRISE BAY AREA AND. I'M
ACTUALLY IN BETWEEN I THINK I
CAN UP ON THE WRONG- BLIND BUT
I WILL SUPPORT THE CONCEPT. IF
YOU TO DEMANDED WITH THREE KIND
OF POWER I'M SORRY I DON'T MEAN
TO INTERRUPT- BUT WE'RE JUST
ASKING AT THIS POINT FOR THOSE
WHO WERE- WEIGHING IN IN
SUPPORT THE JUSTICE STATE THEIR
NAME. AFFILIATION AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL. YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN IRVING ON WE
WILL GO TO LINE THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO HEARING OR
SORRY WE CAN HEAR YOU. YES HI
THIS IS THAT OUR WINE RUG BUT
HE'S VERY CLEAN POWER ALLIANCE
ONE VERY TRUST OUR POSITION TO
BE IN BETWEEN AS WELL I DON'T
KNOW HOW I GOT ON THE QUEUE
BUT- SURE. PROVISION OF VERY
ROSE TO ROUTE RECLAIM OUR POWER.
THANK YOU WE GO NEXT TO LINE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE
LOOKED ON CRESSMAN WITH
ELECTRICITY OF LIFE I'M IN
BETWEEN AND NO MORE I'LL USE AB
I WANT TO- SUPPORT THE
RECLAIMER POWER THING ALSO.
THANK YOU. OR THANK YOU WE GO
NEXT TO LINE THIRTY NINE. WORK
THE GRAYING. YES HELLO MY NAME
IS JAMES VAN I AM A SURVIVOR OF
THE TOUGHEST FIRE AND I
GENERALLY SUPPORT THISBILL AND
I APPRECIATE THE ADDITION OF
THE AMENDMENT EXPLICITLY
STATING SUPPORT FOR
COMPENSATION OF FIRE VICTIMS. I
HAVE ONE REQUEST IS THAT IT
PERHAPS BE MORE SPECIFIC SO
THAT THERE'S NO CONFUSION THAT
THE COMPENSATION FOR FIRE
VICTIMS. WILL BE A COMMENSURATE
WITH EXCUSE ME I KNOW I MEAN TO
I DON'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT BUT
AT THIS POINT IN THE HEARING
WE'RE ONLY HEARING. NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL. AND WE'VE AS WE
MOVE TO THE NEXT SPEAKER PHONE
MODERATOR IF WE COULD JUST
PAUSE FOR JUST A MOMENT I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE MAY BE- A
TRANCE POSE NUMBER ON THE ON
THE- CALL IN NUMBER SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE IT'S CLEAR.
THAT THOSE RECALLED MANNER
CALLING ON THE RIGHT NUMBER.
AREA CODE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN IN THE ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN THREE. TWO SIX TWO FOUR
TWO. AND AGAIN WE'RE ONLY
HEARING FROM THOSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE- THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OR THAT THEIR
TWEENER- BUT BRIEFLY STATE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION.
GIVEN NEXT WE HAVE LINE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS MARK TELL ME FROM THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK. WE
SUPPORT THE BILL ARE CONCERNED
THAT A PROHIBITS CPP ABILITY TO
USE THAT THAN HERRON A THIRTY
HER ABOUT IF YOU NEED THAT TYPE
OF THE WAY FOR TRANSITION THE
GOLDEN STATE POWER. THANK YOU
THANKS TO GO TO LINE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I A
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
CENTER HILL IN OUR MCGUIRE
SPENDER DODD ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN. I WOULD APPRECIATE IT
THIS BILL DOES INTERESTED ON
THE SHOW AND IT'S READY TO GO
IN THE EVENT YEAH I'M SORRY I.
OKAY BUT I'M SAY THIS ONE MORE
TIME AND THEN WE'RE GOING O
JUST HAVE TO CUT YOU OFF I
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF WHAT
YOU'RE SHARING WITH US BUT IT
IS JUST YOUR NAME AFFILIATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL THANK.
YOUR NEXT LINE IS LINE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE FIFTY WHY
WOULD BE WITH THE RECLAIM OUR
POWER COALITION AND THE LOCAL
CLEAN ENERGY ALLIANCE WE
SUPPORT. AS CHAIR OF TWEENER
STATUS REPORT IF AMENDED THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE LINE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS ABOUT THE FELLOW WITH
THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
FACTORS CITY- ALSO IN LINE WITH
MERRY READ THE SENATE BETWEEN
ACTIVE SUPPORT WHAT DOES THE
MAN THANK YOU. THANK. GOING OUT
TO LINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS GLENN WITH
THE RECLAIMER POWER CAMPAIGN-
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF MERRY
RESIDENTS WIENER STAEDTISCHE.
THANK YOU. WE NOW HAVE LINE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MICHIGAN SHARI
WITH THE DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS
OF AMERICA SAN FRANCISCO
CHAPTER- BETWEEN- IN SUPPORT OF
MERRY ROSES- POSITION
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED WITH
PROCLAIM OUR POWER THANK YOU
THANK YOU. PHONE MODERATOR
THERE ANY OTHER. CALLERS FOR A
SUPPORT TWEENER POSITION OR IN
OPPOSITION. WE'LL GO TO LINE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS GENTRY I'M WITH THE
SUN RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND I WOULD
LIKE TO WORRY WAY. AND IT'S
AMENDED WITH THE RECLAIM OUR
POWER CAMPAIGN BY POINT. THANK
YOU. GIVEN NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CARE MEMBER
CHRIS PATTERSON ON BEHALF OF
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC- AGAIN
IN BETWEEN- CATEGORY AS WE
DON'T HAVE A FORMAL POSITION.
ON SB THREE FIFTY HOWEVER WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT WOULD AFFECT.
THE MOTIVATION BEHIND THE BILL-
AND FRANKLY WE HAVE A LOT TO.
AND AT THIS TIME IS FUTURE WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. OKAY AND
THAT COVERS WINNERS IN
OPPOSITION AS WELL RIGHT. AT
THIS TIME- THAT WAS JUST- IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. YOU HAVE LINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI YES- MY NAME IS LINCOLN
OLIVER O'NEILL AND I AM WITH
THE SUNRISE MOVEMENT THERE AND
I WAS PLACED ON THE OPPOSITION
LINE I WAS CALLING AND DURING
SUPPORT AND WAS NOT HEARD- I AM
SUPPORT IF AMENDED INTO LINE
WITH RECLAIM OUR POWER
CAMPAIGNS BY POINTS. THANK YOU.
MODERATORS ARM IF THERE IS
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. I HAVE
NO ONE FURTHER QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU SO NO
ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. THAT'S CORRECT
THANK YOU- WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AND SEE IF IN
A MEMBERS HAVE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. THE CUNNINGHAM THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THE THREE
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR OR FOR
THE SUPPORTING WITNESS- AS YOU
MAY KNOW MY DISTRICT AS A LOT
OF P. JEANNIE EMPLOYEES. IT'S
THE LARGEST EMPLOYER MY
DISTRICT A WE ALSO HAVE WILD
FIRE ISSUES NOTHING OF THE
LIKES THAT HAS BEEN SEEN IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA MIND YOU
BUT- IT'S A SIGNIFICANT RISK
SO- MY FIRST QUESTION IS I
UNDERSTAND THAT. THIS ENTITY
WOULD ASSUME THE LABOR
CONTRACTS OF THE EXISTING
WORKERS BUT MY READ OF THE
BILLS THAT'S ONLY THREE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. AND I'M WONDERING-
IF THE WITNESS COULD ADDRESS
WHY THAT IS AND WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER THAT. MY SECOND QUESTION
IS WHAT SPECIFIC MECHANISMS.
EXCUSE ME EXIST TO PROTECT
VICTIMS IN THE EVENT OF FUTURE.
A FUTURE FIRES UNDER THE GOLDEN
STATE ENTITY CONTRACT- A
CONSTRUCT AND THEN MY LAST
QUESTION IS WHETHER THE AUTHOR.
EVER CONSIDERED A- AT A SUNSET
PROVISION. AND BECAUSE THIS IS
SOMETHING NOVEL OCCURS MEETS.
DIFFERENT KIND OF HYBRID MODEL
HASN'T REALLY BEEN TRIED BEFORE
AND WONDERING IF THERE MIGHT BE
MERIT IN THE EVENT THAT IS
NECESSARY- THIS BILL WOULD TAKE
EFFECT. IT MIGHT BE WORTH
CONSIDERING SOME SORT OF SUNSET
SO APPRECIATE ANSWERS TO THOSE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
CUNNINGHAM V. HAVE FIRST
QUESTION IT GOES TO TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE BECAUSE MINDERS.
THE TERM OF THE CURRENT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT. WITH THE I. B. D. W.
WORKERS AND THEY WILL HAVE
ANOTHER CONTRACT AFTER THAT-
INTO AND IF I AM INCORRECT IN
THESE- MIGHT WITNESS CAN
CERTAINLY- AND I WOULD
APPRECIATE HER SUPPORT AND
THAT. THE WILDFIRES EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE REMEMBER CORRECTLY THE
ISSUES OF WILDFIRES COMING.
FORWARD IN THE FUTURE. IN OTHER
AREAS THAT WILL BE- CERTAINLY.
THE EFFORT IN THE LIABILITY
THAT COMES FROM THAT. WILL GO
TO THE NEW ENTITY GOLDEN STATE
ENERGY. WHERE AS THEY DON'T
HAVE SHAREHOLDER IT WOULD HAVE-
BUT THEY'RE ALSO THE GOLDEN
STATE IT. NOT IN AT THE RATE OF
RETURN THE TEN AND A HALF
PERCENT OR THE BILLION. TO
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN
SHAREHOLDER OFFICE. THOSE AND
IT'S NO LONGER PAYING ANY STATE
INCOME TAX. WILL BE MY THERE
THAT COULD BE USED FOR
WILDFIRES AND IT WILL ALSO BE
PART OF THE WILD- OR FOR THAT
HAVE BEEN CREATED BY THIS. THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
MOVING FORWARD TO UP TO TEST.
THIS IF THE- WHITE FOR FIRE. IN
TERMS OF A- I GUESS THE
CHALLENGE THE THAT I WAS
STRUGGLING WITH ON THAT HE IS
THE GENIE IS WRITTEN. UNDER
YOUR. SOLD UP. AND THIRD LATE
LIFE IT'S A CHANGES THAT I THE
ENERGY OF TWO WHEN LEADERS
CHANGE IT BECAME MUCH MORE.
MUCH OF INTEREST IN THE BOTTOM
LINE THEN THE POWER LINE AND
THAT REALLY BECAME I THINK THE
CHALLENGE FOR THE UTILITY THAT
COULD HAPPEN AGAIN. AND I DON'T
WANT TO TAKE A CHANCE FOR US OR
OUR. TEN YEARS FROM NOW FIFTEEN
YEARS FROM NOW BECAUSE IT COULD
OCCUR IN TRUSTING THE P. YOU
SEE TODAY AS I DO WHERE I DID
NOT TEN YEARS AGO I HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT THIS WOULD ONLY
BE USED IF NECESSARY IN UNDER
THE- THE STRICTEST OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WOULD
WARRANT A MAJOR SHIFT. CHANGE
FROM AN INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY
BUT PUBLIC BENEFIT NONPROFIT
CORPORATION. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION WE SHOULD. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF. MAYES
JUST A FOLLOW UP ON ON THAT
YOU'D SAID AT THE BEGINNING
THIS IS A PROPOSAL THAT YOU
HOPED WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO USE
BUT IT'S THERE IF WE NEEDED A
P. JEANNIE DOESN'T COME COME
OUT OF BANKRUPTCY IS THIS THE
ONLY ENTITY OR COULD THERE BE
COULD THIS BODY COME UP WITH
ANOTHER PROGRAM- FOR INSTANCE
IF THEY DIDN'T COME OUT OF A
BANKRUPTCY COULD YOU NEED THE
SERVICE THESE INTO. TWO DID
DIFFERENT AREA OR IS THIS THE
ONLY MODEL WELL THIS IS THE
THIS IS THE MODEL THAT HAS BEEN
CREATED STE STE- THAT IN THE
EVENT THAT WANTED TO EXIT.
DOESN'T CHECK FINE EIGHTEEN AS-
I SEPTEMBER THIRD WHEN THE BAY.
COULD THE EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT
IS GOING FORWARD AND THE CHILD.
THAT THEY COULD FACE IN THE
FUTURE IF THEY- PLACE
THEMSELVES IN THE SAME
PRECARIOUS POSITION THAT THEY
HAVE IN THE PAST IN TERMS OF
MAINTENANCE IN TERMS OF. THE
VERSION OF RESOURCES FROM.
SAFETY FROM OPERATIONS TO
PROFITS IN AND- BONUSES AND
EXECUTIVES IF THAT IF THAT WERE
TO OCCUR AGAIN. IN THAT WOULD
BE NECESSARY FOR THIS TO OF TO
TRANSITION INTO SOMETHING THAT-
THAT I THINK WOULD BE WARRANTED
I DON'T. THINK THAT IT WILL BE
NECESSARY THERE ARE OTHER
OPTIONS THAT ARE AVAILABLE IF
P. JEANNIE FAILS AT ANY ONE OF
THOSE JUNCTURES. AND THAT WOULD
BE UP TO THE P. IT TO A
RECEIVER THAT WOULD BE
APPOINTED BY THE P. YOU SEE
PERHAPS BY THE COURTS THE
RECEIVER WITHIN LOOK AT OPTIONS
AND OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE LIGHTS STAY ON. IN THE
P. JEANNIE SIR AREA AND THAT
THE YOU CAN CONTINUE TO
FUNCTION. CERTAINLY WITH OUR
LEGISLATION TODAY AND HOPEFULLY
WITH YOUR VOTE TODAY THAT WILL
MOVE THIS GOLDEN STATE ENTERED
INTO A POSITION THAT IT IS. IT
EIGHT. TWO NIMBLY TAKEOVER THAT
OPERATION THROUGH EITHER
EMINENT DOMAIN OR THROUGH A
THROUGH A PURCHASE BECAUSE OF
THE AYE BANK FINANCING THAT'S
AVAILABLE. WILL BE ABLE TO BE
THAT THAT INITIAL. THE BEST
POSITION IN ALL. FOR THE RATE
PAYERS AND CAL. THAT DOESN'T
SAY THAT THERE WILL BE SOMEONE.
LONG THE. A COMPANY THAT
ANOTHER MISTER TO TAILOR MADE
TO PURCHASE THE VEHICLE. IN THE
COMPANY THAT HAPPEN AS WELL BUT
WILL BE IN A- THAT I PUT WILL.
THE BEST SIR IN THE US. TO BE
THAT SAFE YOU. GO FOR BUT THAT
DOES NOT WE'RE NOT ONLY GAME IN
TOWN. IN THE FUTURE. THE OTHER
MEMBERS CHECK YOUR CODE. I JUST
HAVE A FEW COMMENTS- I WANNA
THANK YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN AND SENATOR HILL ON
PUTTING THIS BILL TOGETHER.
I'VE ALL THE WORK THE OF THE
OFFICE OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF
LEGISLATIVE. IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO LET OUR WORK GROUP ON
THE P. GINNY BANKRUPTCY. I HOPE
THIS SUCCESS DEMONSTRATES BUT
TO THE DAM AND MINISTRATION THE
VALUE OF WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. THIS CLOSELY ON
IMPORTANT POLICY INITIATIVES.
WE WERE MINDFUL WE WERE
THOUGHTFUL. THESE RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO STRENGTHEN THE
BILL AND PROVIDE OUR STATE WITH
THE NECESSARY PLAN B. PUBLIC
UTILITY OPTION. SHOULD P. GINNY
AGAIN FAILED TO MEET ITS
RESPONSIBILITIES. MOVING
FORWARD. I'M MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT WORLD FOR VICTIMS AND
REPAIRS IT P. GINNY CONTINUES
TO EXIST VICTIMS OF THE
WILDFIRES COST BY P. GINNY MUST
BE IMMEDIATELY AND FAIRLY
COMPENSATED. FOR THE PAIN AND
LOSS EVEN. IN ADDITION IF THIS
BILL DOES NOT TAKE EFFECT THE
P. YOU SEE MUST BE DILIGENT IN
ASSURING THAT P. GINNY
SHAREHOLDERS ACTUALLY SHARE THE
BURDEN OF THE LIABILITY.
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES P. GINNY HAS
IGNORED OR MISMATCH FOR DECADES.
LET'S REMEMBER REPAIRS DID NOT
CAUSE THIS MESS. THEY SHOULD
NOT AGAIN SHOULDER THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN OF REFORMING
P. GINNY PRACTICE IN MANAGEMENT
IN THE SECOND BANKRUPTCY IN
JUST TWENTY YEARS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY JOIN YOUR COMMITTEE
TODAY FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON SB
THREE FIFTY. FIVE STRESS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I AGREE WITH
THE AUTHOR'S INTENT TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE HAVE A PLAN B.
SHOULD PGA ANY. NOT FAILED TO
ADOPT THE REFORMS CHANGE THEIR
BEHAVIOR AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM WINTERS WORKING
ON THAT COMMITTEE WAS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. AND IT WAS IMPORTANT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE- WORK TOGETHER ON
TRYING TO FIND A SOLUTION-
MISTER TAYLOR PRE SHEET OR
CENTER HELLER PRESHEAF ALL THE
WORK THAT WNT INTO THIS. AT
THE HEART OF THIS IS OUR
FAMILIES WHO DESERVE TO HAVE
RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE ENERGY
WHETHER IT'S PROVIDED BY T. G.
ANY OR GSE. A WHEN I VOTED FOR
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR. YOUR BILL
MISTER CHAIR I KNEW THAT
SOMETHING HAD TO BE DONE AND
THAT JUSTICE NEEDED TO BE
SERVED IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF ALL OF OUR FAMILIES.
I UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR THIS
MEASURE AND I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR WORKING. WITH THE
COMMITTEE WITH THE CHAIR TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS PREVIOUSLY
RAISED BY THIS COMMITTEE. AS
OUTLINED IN THE AMENDMENTS. AND
IN THE ANALYSIS- PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO THE DOSS WHICH OF
NOW BEEN ACCEPTED. I THINK
THESE FURTHER ADD TO
TRANSPARENCY. IN THE CREATION
OF GSE AND I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE MEASURE TODAY.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SO
WISHING TO SPEAK UP SENATOR
HILL AYE DESTROY WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND- THANKING YOU AND
ALSO THE GOVERNOR OF FOR-
RECOGNIZING SOME OF THE
IMPORTANT- AMENDMENTS THAT WE
NEEDED TO MAKE TO THE BILL AND
I. IT WAS ALL IN THE SPIRIT OF
COOPERATION AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR- WORKING WITH THIS AS WAS
MENTIONED- GOVERNANCE AND
TRANSPARENCY ARE VERY IMPORTANT
AND- AS I KNOW YOU KNOW THAT
AND SO- I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR THAT- THANK YOU
FOR ACCEPTING ALL OF THE
AMENDMENTS- AS THE COMMITTEE
MAY KNOW THAT. THE AMENDMENTS
ARE GOING TO ACTUALLY BE TAKEN
UP IN APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE-
WHICH THIS- WILL MOVE TO BE
HERE. THE BILL WILL BE HEARD
TOMORROW. AND SO TODAY WILL BE
A STRAIGHT TO PASS. AND THAT SO
THE MOTION THAT WAS MADE AND
SECONDED. OF CENTER HELP YOU
CAN CLOSE IF YOU WILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR FUTURE AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION TODAY AND- AND THE
THOUGHTS AND CONCERNS EXPRESSED
AND I APPRECIATE THEM IN THE
HARD WORK THAT MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. HAVE PARTICIPATED IN
AND PUT INTO THE LAST SIX
MONTHS WORKING WITH- IN IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE BANKRUPTCY PROCESS
WHICH RUNS CLOSER TO THAT A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF IT. AND
I BELIEVE A BETTER UNDER A
BETTER APPRECIATION OF THE
CREATION OF A PLAN B. WHICH IS
WHAT WE HAVE TODAY IN FRONT OF
US SO I. HAVE LONG STRUGGLED BY
P. GENIES BUSINESS AS USUAL AND
THE UTILITY I THINK WE ALL CAN
AGREE MUST CHANGE. I DESIRE THE.
I DESIRE THE PRESENT BANKRUPTCY
AS AN FOR. AND AS IT IS. TO BE
A- OF CRITICAL REAL IS. FOR
BECOME. THIS TALKING POINTS
PRESS FOR FOLLOWED BY OF AN ACT
JUST WON'T CUT IT ANY LONGER.
AND AS MUCH AS WE PUSH FORWARD
WITH THAT CHANGE WE MUST ALSO
BE PREPARED TO STEP IN. SHOULD
THE COMPANY NOT ME MEET ITS
OBLIGATIONS OR COMMITMENTS IN
THE FUTURE. SB THREE FIFTY IS
OUR PREPARATION I HOPE WHICH
ARE NECESSARY AND IT THAT IT'S
NEVER TRIGGER BUT WE OWE THIS
PREPARATION. TO THE RESIDENTS
OF SAN BRUNO. AND SANTA ROSA.
AND NAPA. IN BUTTE COUNTY IN
PARIS. TO ALL REPAIRS IN P.
JEANNIE SERVICE TERRITORY AND
TO THE STATE LARGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIFLE
ALEX. NO SENATOR I KNOW THEY
WILL HAVE OTHER BILLS THAT WILL
MAKE THEIR WAY TO OUR COMMITTEE
BEFORE THE END OF THE SESSION
BUT I DID WANT TO TAKE THIS
MOMENT AND JUST BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT THIS IS YOUR- YOUR LAST
YEAR- YOU TERM OUT- BUT YOU
HAVE BEEN AND CONTINUE TO BE A
STAND UP. PERSON PERSON A MAN
OF HIS WORD. AND COMMITTED. TO
DOING THE RIGHT THING. AND SO I
JUST WANT THE RECORD TO REFLECT
THAT. THANK YOU TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. HOLDEN HI HOLDEN HIGH
PATTERSON PATTERSON NOT VOTING
BURKE BURKE I CARILLO. CREEL I
CHEN. CHEN NO CUNNINGHAM. I'M
SORRY CUNNINGHAM. NOT VOTING
HELLO NO PARDON ME EGGMAN
EGGMAN I THINK CRISTINA GARCIA.
I EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
I MAYES MAYES I MORE TO CHEAT
MORE TO GI A YOUR CURRY AND
YOUR CAREER I REYES REYES I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I TING TING
I. THE BILL CARRIES ALL MEMBERS
VOTING. IN CASE. THANK YOU
TWELVE IT HEARING THAT TWELVE
IN FAVOR TO OPPOSE AND WE THANK
YOU SENATOR HILL THANK YOU FOR
CALLING WE SHOULD REMOVE SO
MAYBE. YEAH THANK. IF YOU THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED NICK.